Technology is no longer something that's
just restricted to large companies or
large countries or even rich countries.
So everywhere,
uh,
on the planet and now as access,
you know,
at least has the potential to have
access to technology.
People in developing economies often own
smart phones and technologies at
equivalent rates to people in the
developed world.
Uh,
in fact,
quite often they'll have that before
they even have sanitation in some cases.
So the p the pervasive nature of
technology is one of the most important
features of it.
The other important features,
just the rate and pace that rich a
adoption is actually occurring.
Uh,
just to put some comparative numbers on
this,
if you think about television,
it took something like 38 years before
television.
Penate penetration got to the first 50
million people.
Uh,
it took twitter nine months.
so just the rate of acceleration or
reach adoption occurs.
It's pretty phenomenal.
Uh,
the,
and then the other feature that becomes
very interesting about technology is not
just its pace and scale and the rate of
innovation,
but the economic aspects of technology.
So when you have things in digital form
that actually has a profound impact on
how it affects the economics of things.
So digital technologies have this
feature,
uh,
that,
you know,
economists think of it as the nun
rivalry and not exclude excluded ability
of it.
What that means is that my use of
something that's in digital form doesn't
necessarily as a physical,
Technological Matta preclude your use of
it.
The good news about that is that from a
user standpoint,
this is all good because it's what
economists talk about it as consumer
surplus.
So the fact that he doesn't cost us that
much more to get access to information
where there's educational material and
attainment material,
uh,
that's all good for us is as,
as consumers,
I think it puts you challenges for
companies because now you have to think
about how do you generate revenues and
monetize this.
We've seen how technology has caused,
you know,
with these marginal costs,
economics,
disruptions in many,
many,
many industries where this,
the media world,
the entertainment world.
So it has these disruptive effects,
but for users is generally good in the
sense that it's all,
you know,
useful information that you get the
investments in,
in technology,
infrastructure and technology assets is
now pervasive across every sector.
Whether it's we're talking health care
or we're talking,
uh,
the public sector or talking about
education or we talk about industrial.
In fact,
one of the more exciting things about in
the industrial area arena is what
everybody now refers to as the Internet
of things that for the first time we're
now going to be connecting a machines,
centers,
physical things of any sort a that we
like.
I think that's going to have a huge and
profound impact.
So think about all the machine to
machine interactions.
Think about the possibility for how we
manage our use of energy,
how we manage our homes,
how we manage these settings with as to
workspace,
the Ha the home,
the car when machines and things get in,
get connected.
What I find interesting about that in
particular is what that does to a
questions about industry structure and
competition.
I think we always just imagined that,
uh,
you know,
companies would compete within their
sectors.
Uh,
so this idea of these sectors made sense
at some point.
But when you have technology and
technology base to assets,
I think it becomes possible to enter
many,
many sectors on the base of technology
platforms.
Think about the fact that now we're
talking about Amazon as a computing
company,
uh,
through their cloud services.
Think about the fact that you now have
alibaba applying for banking licenses.
Think about the fact that some of the
most profound,
uh,
innovations and transportations are
being done by technology,
Internet companies,
Google and others.
So I think when,
you know,
one of the things that happens to
technology makes it possible for
participants in competition to come from
often outside the sector.
So that's one big change to industry
structure.
Another big change,
the industry structure is on the k on
the question of what it takes to
compete.
So you're now going to see many,
many small companies be able to have
kind of the power and the access and the
potential to disrupt sectors that
historically you'd have associated with
just large companies.
So this idea of competition coming from
outside the sector,
outside of the geography,
and very often from much smaller
companies,
I think it's going to have a profound
impact on the structure of industries in
the economy.